real quick go check out jayatal the uk's
most exciting electronic music duo their
newest release connected is available
wherever you get music it's energetic
melodic blast of electronica ingeniously
infused with acoustic instruments and
they support the david pakman show check
them out using the link below
welcome everybody today we're going to
be sort of resetting taking an overview
of the political climate in the united
states as we're now just what is it it's
about eight uh eight nine weeks
from the 2022 midterm elections and one
of the big
stories one of the big contexts in which
we now have to think about these
midterms and what are the next two years
of american politics sort of going to be
like
is the now extraordinarily notable spike
in president joe biden's approval rating
now we have to also understand context
and the context is this extremely
partisan status quo of the united states
where
your range of approval probably is only
between you know 35 and 65 or something
like that and what i mean by that is
when you
divide up the electorate
into people who just don't pay attention
uh and then those who will always
approve of a democratic president and
disapprove of a republican one and then
those who will always disapprove of a
democratic president and approve of a
republican one and then you say okay
who's actually willing to be swayed and
to sometimes say they approve and
sometimes say they don't not based
simply on the party of the president
you probably only have a functional
approval range of somewhere between 35
and 65 and maybe it's a little wider
than that we used to say it's between 20
and 80. i don't know what it is
right now we are continuing to see joe
biden's approval climb and climb and
climb
now up to 42.4
in an average of approval polls now this
bottomed out
um in mid-may
i'm sorry in uh no not in mid-may in in
the middle of july
at
37.5 so very roughly speaking to go from
37 5 to 42 4
you're talking about a 12 or 13 ish
percent increase not percentage points
everybody relax
percent 12 to 13 percent increase
roughly you can check my math on that
remember the storyline that at this
point we used to say at this point in
joe biden's presidency he is less
popular than every president dating all
the way back to truman and i believe it
was 46.
we used to say that we have a very
different situation now not only has joe
biden's approval rating gone up at a
dramatic rate
but joe biden now and i'll pull these
numbers up for you joe biden now has
pulled even with donald trump in terms
of approval at this point in their
respective presidencies
joe biden has pulled roughly even with
bill clinton at this point in their
respective presidencies even if you look
at reagan
biden is now basically where reagan was
at this point in his presidency and same
thing if you look at uh jimmy carter as
well and only a couple of points
interestingly enough only a couple of
points below
uh barack obama at this point in time
so what is the meaning of all this what
is the importance of all this well
if people don't show up to vote in the
midterms the importance is essentially
nothing the whole context here is
historically when a president takes the
white house when for example a democrat
takes the white house from a republican
in the first midterm election which
comes two years later
democrats usually don't do well this
might mean if they have the house and
senate they lose both or it might mean
if they if they don't have them they
fall behind by an even greater margin we
saw this in
1994 with bill clinton as an example it
almost always happens
however and we'll look at where the
numbers are maybe wednesday thursday
um as of right now
democrats are favored to maintain
control of the senate potentially even
expanding it beyond the 50-50 majority
they have now with kamala harris's
tie-breaking vote and although the house
is still
statistically very likely it's it's
almost four to one likely to go to uh
republicans
there are now paths to democrats keeping
control of the house now i'm not first
of all i'm not making any predictions
but i'm not i'm not predicting that
democrats are going to keep the house
but there is now a story to be told
there is now a path
in which you could make that case but it
all depends on turnout the 2018 midterm
turnout was 53 percent and that was the
highest midterm turnout in four decades
what i mean by that is midterm turnout
is normally very very low you don't
normally get even 53 turnout i think the
last presidential we had roughly 60
turnout so
it is
i know it's cliche at this point to say
it but it will come down to who actually
gets voters out and it is an opportunity
with joe biden's spiking approval
the humiliation that is taking place for
trump and the mega movement
it's an opportunity for democrats to do
something that would not be historically
indicated
based on what we have seen in midterms
in the past we'll update the numbers on
house and senate wednesday thursday by
the end of the week
one of the biggest successes and of
paramount importance
for what joe biden has done in this
presidency so far is something that has
barely made headlines and it is that joe
biden has confirmed more judges
than trump
obama and george w bush at this point in
their respective presidencies it is not
the supreme court that's absolutely true
but it is of massive massive importance
business insider and others talking
about this how biden out did trump obama
and george w bush in confirming federal
judges by this point in office a feat
overshadowed by war and inflation and it
has been
joe biden has confirmed more federal
judges at this point in his tenure than
any president since jfk
biden's court picks have also been the
most racially ethnically and gender
diverse
but his judicial winds have been
overshadowed by news of inflation war
and the fbi mar-a-lago search this is a
major major deal as of august 8th which
was 566 days into biden's tenure the
senate had already confirmed a
record-setting 75 judges nominated by
biden to federal courts according to the
pew research center trump didn't do that
obama didn't do that george w bush
didn't have those numbers you have to go
back to jfk who at this point in his
presidency we're talking about the 60s
folks
had confirmed 102 judges
as of august 26th joe biden had gone
from 75 to 78 and that includes appeals
and district court judges along with one
supreme court justice
this is interesting because
i mean listen
biden is not incorrectly seen as boring
and milk toast
it's just what it is in a sense you
could make the case that that's exactly
what the country needed to sort of
recover from donald trump a guy who
every day was ridiculing a disabled
journalist drawing with a sharpie on a
hurricane map i'm not going to give you
the list i'd have to sit here for five
hours giving you the list
and
when you take a guy
who's
you could say his the reasons many
people didn't like biden
include
he's been in dc for a generation
and um he's not
exciting in the sense that
certain candidates are and i i want to
be careful here because
some of these aren't really criticisms
but they they were used as criticisms
what during the primary
um relatively centrist uh
seeming
but actually on paper
was the most progressive democratic
nominee that i can remember i mean on
paper biden was to the left of barack
obama
the things that joe biden has done and
there are many criticisms of uh there
are many criticisms of the biden
administration
without a doubt i mean every presidency
has criticisms but
quietly for giving more student loan
debt than any president in history
quietly getting more judges confirmed at
this point in his presidency than any
president dating back to john f kennedy
in a sense you could argue that this was
maybe exactly what was needed
to get out of or to recover from donald
trump someone completely predictable
right i mean this was i kept saying
during the primary
all of these people saying biden's going
to be some secret right winger
or biden's going to be some secret
communist never believable but the
people on the right were saying that no
biden was going to be a completely
predictable
center-left democrat who on paper
is the most left-leaning democratic
nominee
at least in in many many decades
and that's what it's worked out to be
and so i can give you my list of the
things i would love for joe biden to do
that he hasn't done
what happened to health care reform what
about decriminalizing cannabis what
about of course we can always come up
with lists of things we would like
presidents to do that they have not done
but it is starting to be remarkable
the amount that actually has been
accomplished and much of it with
extraordinarily little fanfare and i
have to say this this isn't like gushing
praise it's just sort of a trait of joe
biden
he does it without the self-centered
bombast
of somebody like donald trump and
when you expect because of the trump era
a president
to be
tooting his own horn or you could use
you know more graphic metaphors than
that if you want
um about the things that they have
accomplished trump did it about things
he didn't even really do right we built
the wall no you didn't what are you
talking about
you didn't build the wall anyway because
joe biden doesn't do that i think that's
part of why many of these
accomplishments have been have been
quietly done and also that stories like
ukraine inflation and others have
pervaded the news to a greater degree so
i'm as curious as anybody else
where will joe biden's approval be
on midterm election day in just eight or
nine weeks and what impact will that
have on democrats ability to hold the
senate and although it's less likely
potentially hold the hold the house and
we'll update those numbers for you later
this week remember that this wednesday
august 31st 6 pm eastern we're doing a
member only david pakman show town hall
this will be limited in terms of
participation to our website members
anybody can watch it'll be streaming
live on youtube twitch and facebook at 6
pm eastern only our website members will
be invited to participate in this one
and you can add yourself to that
exclusive group of people
uh by signing up at joinedpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is jayatal
jayatel is a stellar melodic dance music
duo in one of the uk's most exciting
electronic acts
jaetal have made their name through
legendary live shows that incorporate
drums guitar electronics taking them on
tours across europe they've appeared on
bbc their newest release called
connected will knock you off your feet
written and recorded entirely remotely
during covid my favorite track from the
album is the one you're hearing right
now called it's coming round again
[Music]
probably because i'm a drummer but i
love acoustic drums accompanied by a bed
of electronic layers and the track
really gets the drums going in all of
their music even something as simple as
the synth bass sounds like it was
carefully adjusted for hours to hit your
ear just the right way these guys will
take you on a journey and jayatal are
big fans of the david pakman show if you
like unusual but deeply gratifying
electronica check out jayatal on their
new release connected wherever you
stream or buy music they're on youtube
and social media you can book them for a
show and you can find them using the
link below
lawyers are increasingly predicting that
failed former president donald trump is
inevitably going to be indicted and
we're going to look at one of those
op-eds momentarily now there are many
people asking if trump is indicted
is he going to be arrested and
perp-walked and booked at a federal
prison
the way that
many so-called normal people are and i
believe the answer is obviously not and
we're going to get back to that in a
moment but let's first start with the
case that is increasingly being made
very interesting article in the daily
beast by brad moss who says it's over
trump will be indicted the case is as
follows uh brad moss says donald trump
will be indicted by a federal grand jury
and he believes that the reason for that
is as follows
number one trump was in unauthorized
possession of national defense
information namely properly marked
classified documents number two trump
was put on notice by the u.s government
that he was not permitted to retain
those documents at mar-a-lago
and number three
trump continued to maintain possession
of the documents and allegedly undertook
efforts to conceal them in different
places throughout the property up until
the fbi finally executed a search
warrant earlier this month and moss says
this is the ball game folks absent some
unforeseen change in factual or legal
circumstances
he believes there is little left for the
justice department to do
but to decide do you indict before the
midterms or after the midterms in terms
of what you ask for the grand jury and
as moss also points out the cruelest
irony for trump is it never needed to be
this way and that's a theme with donald
trump much of the uh problems that
donald trump uh gets into
many of the problems are a result of
trump's own doing and self-inflicted
harm so let's now think this through if
trump is indicted will he be arrested
book purp walked at a federal prison the
answer is almost certainly not uh donald
trump will almost certainly be given the
opportunity to present himself uh to the
fbi on his own terms
and it's all going to be handled in a
very different way than it is with
so-called mere mortals and i use that
term extraordinarily sarcastically now
there is a counterpoint to that
which is when you look at what trump is
being investigated for based on all of
the documents that we now have
when you're talking about espionage act
violations
you often don't give those people a
chance to turn themselves in you arrest
them and that's an absolutely perfectly
natural analysis
but it's trump it's trump and we have to
set our expectations correctly the fbi
and secret service would almost
certainly just coordinate the delivery
of trump to the justice department uh
trump will probably be not by the way i
i
you know if in let's not get ahead of
ourselves if and when this happens it's
going to be a historic and historic
moment it's going to be both in american
history unquestionably and they will say
it's unprecedented
and that means it's wrong well no trump
did things no president did so now the
outcomes are also different than they
were with any other president but
donald trump is almost certainly going
to fundraise off of this if donald trump
is indicted and he's given some bail
amount
he is going to fundraise off of it it's
going to be absolutely incredible to see
donald trump doing this so i think if we
want to be as realistic as possible i
would put out of your minds that you're
going to see trump in an orange jumpsuit
behind bars
i would bet anything i have that that's
not going to happen i'm with you
that trump and the people around him who
were complicit in what are now
countless instances of wrongdoing
they deserve to be prosecuted and found
found guilty in prison there's no doubt
about it but even just think about it i
mean trump in a federal prison like even
if it was even if it was plausible that
trump would be sentenced
it is a national security risk to have a
former president in a federal prison
it's an insane conversation that we're
even having but if i think ahead five
six seven eight steps
and i think about if there are charges
and if there's a conviction or a plea
deal that involves some kind of uh uh
serious consequence
it's trump restricted to one of his
luxury clubs right i mean i think we
would all probably agree that's the
direction it goes but the big headline
is not that that's speculative that's
about the future the big headline is
lawyers increasingly believe trump is
going to be indicted and the growing
question is what exactly is donald
trump's legal defense going to be and
that's what i want to talk about next
there's a very interesting article from
the new york times called trump's legal
defense legal team scrambling to find an
argument
and this article
really puts in focus that there is no
defense here
so far
the strategy has been throw everything
you can at the wall whether it's ketchup
or whatever else you have throw it all
at the wall and see what sticks you
might remember that at one point when we
started learning about
these documents at mar-a-lago at one
point the argument was
there were no documents there that were
controlled by or taken by trump that was
all planted by the fbi that was one
argument they threw at the wall it
didn't stick so very quickly that
changed too
it wasn't illegal for trump to have
these documents at his house because
trump as the president can declassify
whatever materials he wants
and also
laws governing classified materials
don't even apply to presidents of the
united states well but so hold on a
second were they planted by the fbi or
did he have them but they were
declassified or did he have them and
they were classified but it didn't
matter because he used to be the
president which is it but then we
learned oh the crimes he's being
investigated for
it's not actually relevant whether they
were or were not classified
because of how the laws actually are
around the documents that he had oh well
so forget all of that anyway for that
then none of that matters so then it was
listen
we cooperated
trump cooperated all along
trump returned the documents uh trump
stored the documents behind a lock and
key at mar-a-lago just like he was asked
to do
but then we got the affidavit unsealed
and in the affidavit there was nothing
about a lock it just there was just
nothing about a lock the story they kept
telling us we were told put a lock on
the that the door and then you'll you'll
be all good
the affidavit doesn't say anything about
a lock it was about concerns as to how
they were being stored but nothing about
a lock so then some of donald trump's
advisors have started to insist well
it wasn't trump who moved and put the
documents there anyway it was the
general services administration so
you've got to go and talk to the general
services administration except the gsa
has completely denied this we didn't we
didn't take any documents we didn't put
any documents in mar-a-lago this has
absolutely nothing to do with us so then
at another point they shifted to obama
did it too
with 30 000 documents not with 300 or
700 or whatever the number is
that's not true and it's also irrelevant
you can't say listen i may have murdered
someone but other murders have been
committed as well so you can't come
after me unfortunately or fortunately
depending on your perspective that's not
the way the legal system works
then they floated and this one is just
so absurd
they floated trump likes to take work
home uh for a job he no longer has
he's no longer the president of the
united states what does that mean and
then
trump wanted these documents for his
memoirs folks trump doesn't read or
write what are you talking about trump
wanted these for his memoir so the
reality is very quickly becoming there
is no explanation that makes sense and
trump's
cadre of lawyers some of whom he
reportedly hired just from seeing them
on tv
is having a serious problem now in
figuring out how are we going to
mount a legal defense here they will
mount one how are we going to mount a
coherent legal defense if and or when
donald trump is indeed indicted it's
going to be quite a mess
lindsey graham is now threatening riots
if donald trump is indicted
now this is being reported as lindsey
graham
predicts riots if donald trump gets
indicted but the reality is that lindsey
graham is threatening the riots it's his
followers who would be doing the rioting
now
lindsay could say
right wingers would never do that
but he's not saying that right wingers
is saying
our side will riot in the street if
donald trump is indicted and it is
indeed a threat check this out this is
an interview that lindsay gave to fox
news over the weekend very very quickly
garnering millions of views and
understand
this is a threat
he is saying you'd better not do it and
i'm going to give you the two reasons
why he's saying this say this
if there's a prosecution of donald trump
for mishandling classified information
after the clinton debacle which you
presided over and did a hell of a good
job there'll be riots in the streets
right there will be riots in the streets
now first and foremost i thought right
wingers never rioted remember it was blm
that does the rioting it was antifa that
does the rioting it might have even been
people pretending to be trumpets but
really left wingers on january 6 who
were dressed up
as trumpists and had trump stuff on
their social media dating back years but
it was all a ruse they were really left
wingers because right wingers would
never ever ever riot and now lindsay is
saying there will be riots if trump is
indicted this is what they do
lindsay is planting the seeds when he
says i predict that there might be riots
he is getting
right wingers to think about what will
we do if there is an indictment of trump
now when we learned about the search
warrant being served at mar-a-lago trump
has started showing up in large groups
at mar-a-lago and elsewhere and it
didn't get violent fortunately but it
was very clear that they are willing to
get out there in the real world well now
you've got lindsay saying i predict that
there will be riots really lindsay who
will be doing it it's not going to be
black lives matter or antifa it's going
to be trumpists so they are now planting
the seed now afterwards they might say
it was antifa anyway you know they they
love these dystopian headlines portland
oregon has been eliminated from the map
after antifa detonated a suitcase nuke
that never what are you talking about
that never happened portland's fine
portland's still there
um and so here's the the goal of what
lindsey graham is saying there's two
um purposes to lindsey graham coming out
and saying this the first purpose is
if we start sending a signal to the
justice department that it will get very
violent and very hectic and very riotous
and dystopian in the streets of america
if trump is indicted maybe we can
prevent an indictment altogether so
that's like the priority number one
would be
maybe i can start sending these signals
and trump won't get indicted at all the
justice department might say there's too
much fallout there's too much risk we're
not going to do it
the second part of it of course is the
obvious one which is start to get the
political allies and the right wingers
comfortable with the idea that it would
be correct for there to be violence in
the streets because if people like
lindsay and others start saying
this would be so unfair
this would be so bad this would be so
improper
if trump were to be indicted
that it would obviously lead to riots in
the streets they're essentially
normalizing the writing
and whether the idea there is to maybe
prevent the right wingers from getting
in as much trouble as they did after
january 6th or whatever the point is
start to normalize the idea that if this
happened
violence would be appropriate
that is another element of this it's
stochastic terrorism in a way which
we've talked about before they're really
very dangerously on the line of straight
up encouraging the violence but
understand that the headline is bs the
headline lindsey graham predicts
violence no no lindsey graham is
threatening violence lindsey graham is
promising violence and he seems to be
saying it would be justified and that's
an extraordinarily scary place to be
when one of 100 sitting senators is
planting the idea of violence in the
minds of a group of people
that are willing to do violence and
property destruction and everything we
saw on january 6. really scary stuff
we'll have this clip of lindsay on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to join
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the failed former president donald trump
has resurfaced
and he appeared on a program where you
know that phrase if a tree falls in the
woods and nobody hears it does the tree
really does it make a noise it's
something like that anyway um he
appeared on something called the great
america show hosted by lou dobbs you
might remember lou dobbs from
cnn previously and i think he was on fox
at one point i don't know what this show
is but if you have a show that nobody
knows about and nobody watches
does it really exist and i don't know
the answer to that but trump is as
unhinged and incoherent as ever
i challenge you spot the number of lies
in just this first short clip well we
wouldn't have inflation we wouldn't have
the problems that we have would have an
economy that would be roaring we'd have
two dollar gasoline or less okay so
trump says if he were president we
wouldn't have impli inflation and gas
would be under two bucks a gallon and
the inflation would be the economy would
be roaring now think that through does
anyone believe outside of this
completely deranged maga world that if
trump were president
every country would see inflation
and high gas prices
except for the united states somehow in
his infinite genius and big a brain
donald trump would be the be able to do
something to make the united states the
one country that doesn't experience the
global inflation that we've seen and
doesn't experience the global increase
in gas prices that we have seen it
doesn't make any sense the really funny
thing is trump says if i were president
the economy would be roaring by
basically every every metric the economy
is doing great right now i i i'm not
diminishing or devaluing
the real struggles that exist in the
american economy poverty hunger wage of
course that nothing has changed
by every major indicator however the
economy is very strong
gas prices down inflation down job
creation doubled expectations in july
the most recent month for which we have
data stock market
is choppy the last few days but but
significantly stabilized and a great
month in in july and overall looking
very good um oh you know i could give
you the full list we've looked at the so
if trump were president the economy
would be roaring if trump were president
and the economy were exactly as it is
today
trump would claim it's the best economy
in the history of the united states
frankly and we would be dominant in
energy we wouldn't only be energy
independent like we were we would be by
this time dominant we would be the
dominant energy force now understand
that trump has had to shift his story on
that a little bit trump used to say
under me
we were energy independent and we no
longer are under joe biden the numbers
are now so readily available and so
present
and they've been repeated so many times
we actually are just as independent as
we were under trump currently
on fossil fuels of course and so trump
has had to shift to say we would have
gone from independent to dominant
it's just a disaster the windmills are
destroying you take a look destroying
our beautiful open spaces and our planes
and our valleys and you just look at
what's happening to the country with now
does trump say when trump says that the
windmills are destroying planes i assume
he doesn't mean airplanes i assume he
means like the great plains or whatever
and of course they're they're doing no
such thing and we've talked a lot about
yes wind power has a carbon footprint uh
and wind power also has
you know
like many forms of energy you also have
things you then have to dispose of like
the um
wind farm blades etc uh but wind power
is is a great thing these windmills that
are so horrible they're all made in
china and germany by the way but they're
all made outside of the united states
it's a shame what's happened to our
country and it truly is it's a country
that's failing it's the country in
decline
and it's very sad to watch and then they
weaponize they weaponize at a level that
nobody's ever seen before they go after
political opponents at a level that
nobody's ever seen before right well i
mean listen trump quite literally
attacked the media ridiculed people's
appearance was a dystopian authoritarian
wannabe but it's it's democrats now who
are doing things to their political
enemies in a way that we've never seen
before that's completely and totally
absurd trump then continuing on this
extraordinarily bizarre program and he
seems to
be sort of grasping at what he believes
are relevant straws
when in reality they very much are not
continue to listen to this i did nothing
wrong and it's the exact same thing here
we were
essentially attacked we were broken into
they opened up safes they brought state
crackers in now understand
this was a legal
search warrant the search warrant listed
the safe
they're allowed to look in the places
delineated in the search warrant this is
another narrative that only will work on
people who either aren't paying
attention or are a little bit dim
this was an illegal thing that took
place
this was essentially a burglary of
mar-a-lago there was a search warrant
there was an affidavit the uh
fbi director signed off on this
the attorney general signed off on this
a judge signed off on it they gave trump
every opportunity every opportunity to
prevent this
it was completely and perfectly legal
but they want to convince people it was
some kind of strong-armed burglary
they've brought many many fbi agents in
oh yeah all right before the midterms
and all when i have the best poll
numbers i've ever had this is a
political attack on our country now i
don't know what poll numbers he's
talking about but i've not been able to
find evidence of what he's saying and
it's a disgrace and the people
understand it the people understand it
and they could have come in and they
could have talked to us and they could
have taken whatever they needed and they
did
understand that this is another part of
the story one part of the story is this
was essentially a burglary these were
thugs who came in and cracked my safe
um
it was a home invasion the other part of
it of course is they could have just
asked me for what they wanted and now we
have the paper trail on that as well
they did ask numerous times and in fact
trump lawyers
we still don't know whether the trump
lawyers believed it when they said it or
not but trump lawyers said
we've turned everything over we've we've
turned it all over
when indeed they had not trump was given
every opportunity to prevent this but
instead they raided it they took my
passports
they they took things that they should
have never taken with
uh that are privileged
and it's a disgrace to our country it
really is it's just and it just never
ends it's the same people the same leaks
the same uh
they leak to the same places the same
people doing the
it's a disgrace it's a disgrace our
country's a wreck yep so essentially
nothing true there and continuing to
pull this i'm a victim i'm a victim i'm
a victim i'm a victim now that is not
going to work
in court
if it gets to that point
it is no longer going to be a valid
excuse in the court of public opinion it
has worked quite well i mean you go to
events the standouts in florida and
other places where trumpists are
interviewed and they have fallen for the
trump's really the victim eric trump
goes on fox news and speaks in place and
says we're the nobody's been treated as
poorly as we've been treated but that's
not going to work in court so that's
trump on the great america show with lou
dobbs let's take a look at the truth
social stuff next so
we are going to talk on the bonus show
today about how terribly donald trump's
social media platform truth social is
doing truth essential yes truth central
as some people know it donald trump
yesterday
spent a bunch of time on truth social
just flipping out and you can tell
this guy is panicking
this guy realizes the walls are closing
in around him
the lawyers he picked from just seeing
them on tv
don't seem to be representing him in the
most
uh coherent and competent way
and donald trump with another one of
these multi-post tirades that used to be
reserved for twitter
until trump was banned trump kicking it
off with the
now emblematic all caps witch hunt with
three exclamation points you know i
actually respect three exclamation
points when i see two
it's a little weird but you know if you
want to do one exclamation point or
three i can get behind that so at least
trump with three exclamation points then
trump posting quote
when are the great agents and others in
the fbi
going to say we aren't going to take it
anymore
much as they did when james comey read
off a list of all of crooked hillary
clinton's crimes
only to say that no reasonable
prosecutor would prosecute the wonderful
people of the fbi went absolutely nuts
so comey had to backtrack and do a fake
investigation
in order to keep them at bay the end
result we won in 2016 and we did much
better in 2020 but now the left has lost
their minds
that is a wild wild assertion
it's gobbledygook it's a verbal inkblot
well it's a i guess it's a written one
um that doesn't make any sense
and trump just not relenting continuing
with quote the raid on my home
mar-a-lago
is one of the most egregious assaults on
democracy in the history of our capital
c country
which is by the way
going to places in a very bad way it has
never seen before and then lastly
back to all caps
invasion of privacy
and again this could be referring to
anything this could be referring to
uh the raid on mar-a-lago itself this
could be referring to
what's in the affidavit i mean with
donald trump you never really know
this is a very
scared
but also incompetent
delusional
and narcissistic individual
and what summer's now suggesting is that
when you take remember trump never
apologizes trump never thinks he did
anything wrong he never takes
responsibility that's been the theme
typical of narcissists
what some are now starting to speculate
is that this
it's it's always been unhinged but
there's something uniquely unhinged
about about this
that trump now is starting to be the
authoritarian dictator wannabe
narcissist
who is starting to believe
the walls may be closing in around me
and
one of the
difficulties
when such people start to believe that
is that i hate to use this analogy
because
i'm not literally comparing people to
animals but when cornered animals
uh realize they are cornered sometimes
they start to behave in ways that are
extremely out of character unpredictable
erratic and dangerous
and when you take a true narcissist who
never apologizes never admits that he's
done anything wrong and believes he's
always so
he believes he's so much smarter than
everybody else that if you just let him
talk to them he'll talk his way out of
an indictment an investigation whatever
when they start to think wow i really
may be screwed here
all bets are off about what they might
be willing to do and we may well be
getting to that spot with donald trump
the next two months are going to be nuts
next two months are going to be truly
truly nuts
we're going to take a very quick break
make sure you're following us on
facebook facebook.com davidpakmanshow
and remember uh that wednesday
this wednesday august 31st at 6 pm
eastern we will be doing the members
only town hall
if you'd like to participate sign up at
joinpackman.com
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow well folks rudy giuliani
now admits
that he did the massive dumps um it the
the jokes right themselves at this point
in time like how can i add anything and
i'll be completely upfront
this is just
comedic insanity period
there is no
credibility to rudy giuliani at this
point
there is no
i mean the guy is as backwards as
anybody we've seen affiliated with
american politics in the last many years
rudy giuliani went on newsmax
and he told eric balling
he did the big dump and for those of you
who have been following this entire
massive dumps storyline for the last
couple years
this will be particularly odd uh check
this out so here they're saying things
like there's gonna be a big dump and
there was a big dump
i put out the big dump to the new york
post
oh guys i i
i can't do it any longer i just can't do
it if you um
if they if they wanted to joke about the
whole dumps thing and at snl's writing
room
someone came up with this fake giuliani
saying this
they would be looked at like what what
are you 10 years old what are you
talking about a dump what do you mean it
doesn't make any sense nobody would
believe that now rudy's also going to go
out and talk about a big dump
and then here it is now as a reminder
this all goes back to this infamous
um uh historic moment historic moment in
american political history and what
happened if you watched the election i
was called by the biggest people
uh saying congratulations political
people congratulations sir you just won
the election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and i'm sure you
felt that way
this election was over and then they did
dumps right they call them dumps big
massive dumps
uh in michigan and pennsylvania
and maria bartoromo's eyeglass
adjustment right when trump says massive
dumps is still just i mean absolutely
perfect so what is this all about you i
know many of you are going to be shocked
by this all of this stuff that rudy's
saying the dumps and everything
the context is the hunter biden laptop
story
i know it's it's unbelievable but
they're still talking about hunter
biden's laptop so here is a little more
of the rudy interview
it's actually interesting to in the
middle of unprecedented legal problems
for donald trump
they're talking about the hunter biden
laptop mr mayor since when does the fbi
tell a private company like facebook
what to publish and what not to publish
i mean
about national security information
that's a good point
wow i mean when did they when did when
did they do that
that's a very very good point national
that happens to be about the time that i
was communicating with john mack isaacs
and the fbi had seized a year earlier
my my uh icloud account so here they're
saying things like there's going to be a
big dump
and there was a big dump yeah i put out
the big dump to the new york post right
but that was a three week period in
which
i was communicating with bob costello
and john mack isaacs we were going back
and forth
imagine trying to follow this and we
were doing our own due diligence to make
sure
that what he had was legitimate yeah and
then there was a big dump
and he
censored it
and you know what that indicates the
government was part of that yeah that
makes all this first amendment stuff
very different one of the ways they get
out of the first amendment is they say
these are private companies but the
minute the government's conspiring like
that it's the government violating
first amendment rights amazing amazing
the fbi reaches out to zuckerberg and
and and facebook goes ahead and
throttles back the story twitter set
twitter went even further and just
completely pulled the story
miranda devine called me before and
corrected that oh she said that facebook
was the first twitter followed facebook
yeah and but
twitter went a little bit mr mayor
always good to have you on uh we'll talk
to you all right so they're not really
understanding each other but what's
clear is that
rudy was the source of the dump and i
mean it's this is american politics at
this point in time meanwhile i mean
listen i have to tell you folks
i'm glad to say
that while
the second half of the show
has been me catching you up on
rudy's dumping and
trump's lying on a show no one's heard
of hosted by lou dobbs and it's just
it's almost sad like they're in the
toilet for lack of a better term
it's great that the first half of the
show was
look at joe biden's achievement on
judges
look at how
the approval rating of biden is reacting
to material substantive significant
accomplishments including student loan
student loan debt relief and the jobs
report the inflation reduction act the
pact act and on and on
it's nice that we have some sanity again
and that we have an approval rating at
least within some range responding to
the actions of the president and it's
because i mean
it's they're in the toilet on the right
guys they're in the toilet on the right
and if you think rudy's massive dumps
are disgusting
look at what i'm going to talk to you
about next
donald trump jr
who is just
desperate for his father to like him
just desperate for his father to like
him
he posted what are essentially dick pics
of his dad
um
look at this image we're putting up on
the screen for you and no it's not
x-rated
um
sort of i guess like making fun of the
redactions in the affidavit that was
released related to the raid on
mar-a-lago
jr put out on instagram
an image of an obese trump on the golf
course
with
a redaction over what would be very
large genitals
suggesting that you would need such a
redaction if trump's
pants were off i mean listen to what
these people are doing to the country
they're laughing at us around the world
in his desperation for his dad to like
him don jr
did a fake dick pic meme suggesting his
dad is extraordinarily well in doubt
would the tagline redact this
and the way that this is written up
in different news outlets it's nobody
even knows how to cover this stuff
donald trump jr
posts obscene meme
about his father's crotch
junior responded to the release of the
heavily redacted affidavit that provided
justification for the search of
mar-a-lago by posting a meme on his
instagram of trump
with a comically large
black bar
over his crotch
redacted trump jr captioned the photo
oh my god
the meme follows similarly solicitous
comments from arizona's republican
gubernatorial candidate carrie lake who
recently said that trump and desantis
have bde also known as big
d i have to be careful for our radio
affiliates big d energy
trump made the same claim about his own
genitalia during a 2016 republican
primary debate when rubio
made a crack about the size of trump's
hands
uh stormy daniels reports trump has an
unusual penis
guys
what the hell is happening
uh huffington post don jr posts a quote
dick pic of dad
after affidavit release
quote redact this
always the intellectual donald trump jr
on friday came up with an innovative way
to respond to the public release of the
affidavit posted a picture of trump and
his golf duds with a long black bar over
his crotch
this is listen folks
the right loves to say
isn't this great these are just like
normal people like me and you
most normal people wouldn't do this
a lot of people if they were posting
this type of stuff they might lose their
job so it's actually very much not like
you and me at least i i've never posted
pictures like this to the internet let
me put it that way um so that's the
latest there
just an incredible incredible incredible
humiliating situation we have a
voicemail number and that number is 2192
david p our friend the eggman called in
he's starting to think maybe there
really is a deep state listen to this
hey guys is there legitimately a deep
state
okay think about it okay just recently
joe rogan and
uh
uh
alex jones both are starting coming out
for desantis on their radio shows okay
okay these radio programs that are
national that have this right wing
leaning that have very low iq listeners
and low iq speakers right true to are
all starting to pop up to santa's
descent it's all over is somebody
controlling that is somebody leaving
that
that's a republican deep state that's a
right-wing deep state there's more
evidence of that no there's none i made
it up but there's more evidence of that
than the democrat deep state why don't
the dems say who's controlling all this
media who's causing the media to flip
from trump to desantis yeah somebody's
controlling this there's a right-wing
deep state who is it whose hand is on
the button
i think the dems need to change the way
we talk about this stuff okay there's
something going on or maybe it's not i
don't know
shalom all right shalom to the eggman
yeah the eggman's completely right i
mean just like imagine a different
scenario okay
imagine the scenario the real world
right now which is joe biden's the
president and again we don't know if joe
biden's running for re-election we just
don't know right now
imagine if all of a sudden
every left-wing show you you turn on
this show and i'm talking about you know
just whoever just makes something
hillary clinton like this actually is
the perfect example imagine that you
turn on the david pakman show
and i am for some reason talking about
how
i think it's over for biden and we need
to get hillary to be the 24 nominee and
then you turn on msnbc
and they're saying it's time for hillary
to come back and you turn on tom hartman
and tom's saying we've got to draft
hillary clinton or whatever
of course these right-wingers would
immediately say this is evidence of the
deep state somehow even though biden's
president you are seeing a coordinated
and calculated effort to rehabilitate
and resuscitate hillary clinton's
political career to make her the 2024
nominee it's the bilderbergs it's the
trilateral commission it's the
illuminati it's the you know whatever
whatever you want to say uh it might get
worse they it might get anti-semitic as
well
and yet it's actually true
that from somewhere there's a movement
coming that is starting to question
donald trump's place at the top of the
republican party and question trump's
assumed
2024 nomination if he wants it and
they're starting to talk about ron
desantis they're not talking about
anybody else they're not talking about
nikki haley they're not talking about
lindsey graham or
you know whoever they're talking about
ron desantis
and the reason that the left doesn't go
it's a deep state conspiracy it's
because it's absurd
it's absurd what's going on is there are
lots of people who never like trump and
there's still a significant number of
people in the republican party who
publicly go along with trump this
doesn't make them good people by the way
they publicly go along with trump
because they saw the way the tide was
turning and they see the way the wind's
blowing now for now still but they would
rather someone else they believe that
trump has been damaging to the party and
so they'd rather someone else and right
now that's someone else most pointedly
seems to be ron desantis that's it we we
don't go to deep state because there's
no evidence of that and of course it
would be the same thing if all of a
sudden the left started uniting around
someone else even though biden's the
president but the right would
immediately say it's a conspiracy it's a
deep state you're taking your
direction from soros or whoever else
it's going to be
very very good point by the eggman we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today we now have polling do americans
support canceling student debt a
majority do now that doesn't mean that
that's the reason to do it
most people if you go to them and you
say hey would you like your loans paid
off who's going to say no if you come to
me and you say hey do you you want me to
pay off some
sure i guess pay it off but we don't do
things necessarily just because people
want it done but it is interesting that
a majority of voters support this
political decision made by joe biden and
that may have a political impact we will
discuss
there is a uh there's a drought
happening in much of the country in
california there are water bans drought
restrictions that have been put in place
and a whole bunch of different
celebrities are accused of just
violating it they are flouting it not
flaunting flouting you can look that up
kim kardashian sylvester stallone and
others
we are going to talk about the legal
realities of such water bans on the
bonus show and also i do want to update
you about what's going on with donald
trump's platform truth social truth
essential massive financial problems
much like trump with his own lawyers not
paying a number of different vendors
the days may already be numbered for
truth central and i have to tell you it
would just be delightful if the free
market decided that the platform is
trashed and it's trash and it deserves
to be flushed
that would be an absolutely delightful
thing so i would love for you to join us
on the bonus show today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad yeah you're invited to
join us on the bonus show you can sign
up at joinpakman.com and you have the
added benefit if you were to sign up
today that wednesday we're doing our
next
members only
town hall
it will be an exclusive event to
participate in for our members anybody
can watch it'll be streaming live on
youtube tuition facebook but if you want
to participate in the town hall you sign
up at joinpakman.com
and of course you can use the coupon
code obama
get a discount all right sign up we will
see you on the bonus show and i look
forward to seeing you on the town hall
on wednesday
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
real quick go check out jayatal the uk's
most exciting electronic music duo their
newest release connected is available
wherever you get music it's energetic
melodic blast of electronica ingeniously
infused with acoustic instruments and
they support the david pakman show check
them out using the link below